I'm Scott sabonis I run our medical
devices group in Microsoft's healthcare
Microsoft's healthcare is a partner
organization kind of in the MSR family
we're actually in the same building with
everyone else we came out of something
called MSR research next which is a lot
of different projects that are tend to
be incubations that have 5 to 10 to 15
people or more all working on just one
project rather than maybe a researcher
working on a project with a couple other
people are working on multiple projects
so one way my talk is physiological
sensing outside the clinic I want to
give you a little bit of a sense of one
of the things that we do in our medical
devices group you've probably already
been told this many times that our
mission at Microsoft is to empower every
person and every organization on the
plant on the planet to achieve more I
like to say that our group does that by
keeping people alive that's our main
mode of empowerment and so what I want
to do is give you just a quick tour
through one way that we hope to keep
people alive the way we tend to operate
is in in this medical devices space and
healthcare in general there's a lot of
places you could try to intervene and
change outcomes that medical outcomes
that are happening you could invent new
small molecules for example that's
something that you see happen in
pharmaceutical industry and it plays a
really big role in how we develop
healthcare deliver healthcare and a lot
of the changes that have happened an
outcome over the last couple hundred
years we don't make small molecules here
at Microsoft probably not too surprising
to you instead we tend to use computing
in one form or another whether that's
making new devices writing software
building cloud services so instead the
way that we try to have an impact on
healthcare is we like to find places
where there are outcomes that look like
they could be a lot better and then ask
a question is there a role that
computing can play in this scenario to
hopefully create better outcomes than we
have today so I'm going to give you a
quick tour of one project that we're
working on right now but kind of
representative of one way of going about
and doing this work and so this is the
area of heart failure and so heart
failure is a set of conditions where a
sense
your heart is not able to pump enough
blood there's a couple things again
causes but your heart can't pump enough
blood to your body and you don't get
enough oxygen so there are things that
you need to and what tends to happen in
heart failure is you do something called
decompensate you end up in an urgent
situation you tend to find yourself in
an ER and then an ICU and then you get
stabilized and you go home and hopefully
you stay home for quite some time and
you're well for quite some time but
unfortunately 25% of people are
readmitted within 30 days of when they
leave the hospital with heart failure
and so this is exactly the kind of place
where we we ask the question could
computing play a role here to try and do
better so there's a number of things
that you might want to do to try and
help this scenario but most of what it
comes down to is you want to try to
observe really early when something is
going wrong with the patient create an
intervention and hopefully keep them
from ending up in the hospital so
there's a lot of things you measure with
a heart failure patient you might
measure wait to see if they're retaining
fluid you and a lot of other things like
behavior are they able to get up and do
their normal daily activities another
one that you want to do not surprisingly
is just looking at their cardiac cycle
and what is their heart doing one of the
things that you might use to do this in
the clinic is something called the
Tanami tur that you can hold on your
radial artery and it gives you this
waveform I'm not going to explain it all
today because we only have a couple
minutes but think of it as a way to
extract information out about the state
of your cardiovascular system so we've
done in this particular situation they
said okay I think I see how computing to
play a role here will take this thing
you can only do in the hospital today
and do as a workup and let's turn it
into a mobile device that you can wear
under your wrist they can just do this
all the time when you're awake when
you're sleeping whatever and then send
that information back so we make a
device from scratch we then do internal
and external validation that it's the
same kind of signal that you can get
with the kind of device that you use in
clinic today and then we go and test
this hypothesis out in the field so we
just actually finished collecting the
data from a hundred and sixty patients
from each one of them is somebody with
heart failure who wore a device while
they were hospitalized stabilized and
then sent home for 30 days and then we
got the device back from them and now
this is an example of one of these
projects where now what we do is go
through and try to figure out what can
we detect about the changes that
happened for people whose condition
worsened and got readmitted to the
hospital and then in the future what
could we do differently to try to
prevent that readmission that's it
any questions yeah okay hi I'm Kelly
this is a two-parter first uh what did
you study in school just curious I
studied computer science so I have
interesting pure science I actually
interned here at MSR three times and
then came here as a researcher and have
been here ever since
my dissertation was on physiological
sensing with electromyography for
interaction so for computing purposes
and then eventually healthcare computer
science Oh physiological sensing for
computer input and so I guess how did
you coming from like a computer science
background how did you get the
information about health that you needed
was it like a lot of self studying or
collaborating with experts like how did
you branch into that space it's both of
those things so our medical devices team
has a range of different backgrounds in
it so my background is computer science
I'm one of two technical people who is
not a EE so everybody everybody else has
a EE as an undergrad and then something
else for grad school whether it's
electrical engineering biomedical
engineering things like that so we have
a range of expertise but then for each
of these investigations we do we usually
have at least one if not several pis at
academic medical centers in the US or
elsewhere they do the project with us
thank you
hi name is Fabian in terms of future
intervention what do you envision are
you thinking of this as collecting the
data from the patient at home and then
sending that data directly to to you
know the health practitioners or like
the physicians and all that and the
second part of my question is are you
considering situations where you have
like home care workers or community
health workers who are supporting these
people and increasingly going more and
more as the de facto way of taking care
of people chronic diseases in the US
yeah the answer is yes and both of those
questions I think depending on the
disease or the outcome we're trying to
modify there's going to be different
answers I think oftentimes one of the
ways that we can have impact with
computing is to find a scenario where
maybe there's a solution that works but
it involves specialists a lot of
attention a lot of money being spent per
patient and it just can't generalize to
everybody in the US or everyone in the
world and try to find a way where
computing whether that's with a sensor
that can do a lot of work and it doesn't
require as much training to be able to
use the sensing technique or other ways
to make it so that a much broader group
of people can deliver healthcare so in
the case of a home healthcare worker we
want to find ways to build stuff that
can fit into the lives of that patient
and that healthcare worker and help the
healthcare worker like keep that patient
from decline and then being readmitted
to the hospital thank you Scott and
thanks to all the speakers that's the
end of this session
[Applause]
you